I said what in the world is this is the
government which clearly none of us are
loving these days it also lost an F-35
for a couple days in South Carolina this
is absolutely wild from the hill the U.S
military is hunting for an 80 million
dollar F-35 fighter jet after a pilot
ejected from the military aircraft near
Charleston South Carolina on Sunday
officials at Joint Base Charleston said
they were working with a local Marine
base to locate an F-35 that was involved
in a mishap Sunday afternoon the pilot
ejected safely from the Jet and is
receiving medical care if you have any
information that may help our recovery
teams locate the F-35 please call the
base defense operations and blah blah
blah they wrote on Twitter and ladies
and gentlemen in case you haven't seen
it somebody did find the jet fear not I
love this guy this is Randolph white in
South Carolina this guy should is a
national hero as far as I'm concerned
normally it's pretty quiet but on Sunday
afternoon I was in the uh
bathroom taking a shave
and I heard us
I said what in the world is this and I
heard a boom in my whole house show
white says he didn't realize it was a
plane at the time so he didn't call
anybody
beat it right come out of space or
something
and I said well there's the airplane it
needed to be reported let the thing
would fly I swear to God I would rather
have that guy in charge of whatever the
high hell is going on here than Lori
Lightfoot or Anthony fauci or Janet
Yellen
I'm gonna go down and have lunch with
him Drew isn't his story just isn't it
just perfect like they literally lost an
F-35 and they asked people to call them
if they found it like
yeah it's a brilliant example of
government incompetence but you know H.L
menkin said thank goodness we don't get
all the government we pay for you know
so yeah that's me
but I I got to say something I you know
Pilots I talk to keep saying the same
thing which is a a aircraft that is
still flying you don't eject from and so
this mishap that's such a carefully
chosen word they will they will Glide
the plane they will do all kinds of
things with the plane to kind of get it
towards something like a landing or a
safety or unless it's rapidly changing
altitude which they did not say that
they did not say a mechanical error they
did not say a major malfunction they
said some sort of mishap and that is a
bizarre choice of words it's a bizarre
response they couldn't track an F-35 and
where it was going did it was it hacked
was it taken over did the pilot do
something egregious I mean there's
there's lots of possibilities here other
than something routine right well the
major mechanical malfunction they did
not say that and the plane did not lose
altitude before the the pilot took out
to be clear drew the pilot is now
blaming this on bad weather it still
doesn't explain why they lost the plane
after 35 can't fly through bad weather
that's true I want my 85 million dollars
back yeah exactly true it's made by the
government I mean come on